هي اطول المعارك واكثرها دمويه منذ بدء
الغزو الروسي لاوكرانيا مدينه باغموت ما
تزال في مرمى نيران القصف الروسي منذ
يوليو تموز الماضي واصبحت الان تحت رحمه
الطائرات المسيره
بدون طيار وجود جنود اوكرانيين داخل
المنزل تمطرهم بالقذائف وتدمر المنزل على
رؤوسهم
رغم مقاومه الجنود الاوكرانيين ادت
لاشتباكات الى تقدم القوات الروسيه نحو
الضفه الغربيه لنهر هذا ما اكدته وزاره
الدفاع البريطانيه في تغريده روسيا حققت
المزيد من المكاسب وتقدمت على الارجح الى
وسط المدينه ما يهدد طريق الامداد
الاوكراني الرئيسي الى غرب مدينه بخموت
حتى الان لا توجد معلومات رسميه حول عدد
القتلى الاوكرانيين والروس في ضخمه لكن
رئيس مجموعه فاجنر شبه العسكريه اطل في
فيديو مصور من داخل مقبره في روسيا حيث
دفن عشرات المقاتلين من قواته
انظروا الى هذه المقبره نعم انها تتوسع
مصير الذين يقاتلون في غالب الاحيان هو
الموتى هكذا هي الحياه
خسائر فاتحه يتكبدها الجيش الاوكراني
والروسي ووحدات فاجنر تقدر باكثر من 150
الفا بين قتيلا وجريح وفق التقديرات
الغربيه منذ بدء الهجوم الروسيه على
اوكرانيا